there's a tremendous amount of action
that takes place within that carnival
set so it was really important having a
guy like Kyle with whom we had just
worked on Aquaman to be there to create
these amazing action set pieces and to
prepare the actors for the action that
they were going to do in the stunts that
they were gonna do yeah I think the
countable sets fainted nothing but a
challenge all right let's think about
what everyone everyone realized we
needed something a little bit bigger
than the original script intended and
that grew and grew it literally doubled
out while I work wrote goodbye we went
from about 48 sort of our gags
throughout the film and we suddenly
developed 60 just at the carnival line
or try that again Machens acted on arrow
bow in a controlled environment on
center stage
one thing I learned is that the more
spectacular something is on screen the
more boring it probably was to shoot you
know like people flying you know they
have to be rigged into these weird
contraptions you have to rehearse and
rehearse and rehearsal
it pays off in the end yeah it's just a
challenge to get there
you